so now let's look at tucker carlson's
show from last night
understand the signal boosting of these
right-wing conspiracy theories for
months tucker has been saying on his
show without evidence the fbi did the
trump riots he's just been repeating
that repeating that repeating that he
eventually gets on this idea of ray epps
ray epps the oath keepers militia guy
is a fed
or a confidential informant which is a
completely different thing
ted cruz gets sucked into it because ted
cruz says the wrong thing about the
january 6 rioters being terrorists and
he has to go on tucker's show and
apologize at which point tucker starts
talking to him about ray epps
then ted cruz does his good deed of the
day and talks about ray epps during a
senate hearing yesterday and then we go
to last night on tucker carlson's show
where tucker then signal boosts it even
more here is tucker carlson continuing
the ray epps conspiracy theory
and while we're at it here's something
else that's confusing epps is a
long-time right-wing activist as you
know he urged protesters to riot true
video from january 6 shows him at the
forefront right in front of the capitol
appearing to usher others inside
so he wasn't just someone who was there
he was maybe the central figure there he
was not the central figure he obviously
was not the central figure and only if
you believe that does any of the rest of
this even make sense if you listen to
this critically you go wait ray epps was
a central figure it's not clear ray epps
actually committed any crimes at the
capitol
and yet democrats for reasons that
aren't at all clear suddenly seem highly
protective of ray epps they don't want
you to criticize him adam kinzinger
described ray epps today as quote
nothing but a january 6th protest
attendee and remember he says democrats
don't want you talking about him but
adam kinzinger is a republican
really
nothing but an attendee he is of course
the opposite of that of everyone there
ray apps is the one you should be
maddest at if you are the democratic
party what about trump
and yet they're telling you he was an
attendee not an insurrectionist not a
terrorist just an attendee another
engaged american exercising his
constitutional rights now by the way i
haven't found any democrats saying that
ray epps is a you know disgusting
right-wing dude who was there uh the day
before talking about going into the
capitol but i i'm not calling him uh i'm
not saying anything positive about him
other than the the argument that he's a
fed is not based in any fact
that's a huge change it's bizarre it
doesn't make any sense at all
so what's going on here yeah something
is that's for sure and one last question
the committee has assured us that ray
epps wasn't quote employed by working
with or acting at the direction of any
law enforcement agency
okay
but why did the committee stop there
would the committee be willing to
broaden that statement and affirm in
writing that ray apps wasn't working
with any government agency law
enforcement or otherwise that's a very
typical conspiracy thing also which is
no matter what information you
eventually get from people
you say it's not comprehensive enough
it's not full enough they will never be
satisfied with it uh and tucker
continued this i mean it's like
a lot of ray epp stuff on his show it's
wild in other words they really expect
you to believe that quote i simply don't
have any information at all that
individual so the doj knows nothing
about ray apps the guy on the most
wanted list right now that's also not
true
we have a combination of statements
including that he is not um
working
for the fbi
and when ted cruz asked some of his
questions the answers were i can't speak
about individuals in this way and that
would be the answer no matter who the
individual was
that's absurdly false and as if to
underscore how absurdly false it is
within a short time democrats on the
january 6 committee released a statement
claiming that actually they'd already
interviewed ray epps and anyone who
still has questions about his behavior
on january 5th or 6th is a dangerous
conspiracy theorist quote
mr epps informed us the committee said
in a statement today that he was not
working with employed by or acting in
the direction of any law enforcement
agency on january 5th or 6th or at any
other time and that he has never been an
informant for the fbi or any other law
enforcement agency end quote
wow bombshell looks like case closed we
can forget about reyes so then of course
here it's when the denial is not a good
enough denial so these are indefeasible
arguments from tucker you can and which
is common of conspiracy theorists there
is nothing you can present because
evidence in favor is evidence in favor
and evidence or statements against are
also evidence in favor either through to
their due to their alleged
incompleteness or specificity or
whatever the case may be so my instinct
is that these people will never be
satisfied with the ray epps thing but
look at the the way
that tucker was able to use ted cruz to
talk about this on national television
during a senate hearing it's incredible
stuff
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chilly sleep
which makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions to sleep
better their flagship products are the
uhler sleep system and the cube sleep
system which is what i have both are
hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chili blanket which keeps you
cold on top too right now chili sleep is
running a special sale you'll get thirty
percent off everything when you go to
chilisleep.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video